kamala devours another soul leaving her
office deeper in the hole
it's america's fastest growing group
calmly staffers who flew the coop
yes another staffer decides it's no fun
to work for kamala the hun
the chief of staff tina florinoy is
leaving and yet another senior advisor
will take her place next month the last
damn to go through this many seniors was
andrew cuomo
yeah
tina's the highest ranking aide to quit
and the 13th staffer to leave since the
vp took office yeah 13. if one more
employee quits kamala gets a free frosty
at wendy's
there are many theories as to why
commonly staffers leave her and zero
theories as to why they would stay
maybe it's her unpreparedness at
important meetings and speeches maybe
it's the constant tackling when someone
brings up a war or it could be the
cadence of her speech which comes off as
fake strange and off-putting but
maybe we're just getting her wrong
perhaps her speaking style is simply
inspired by the great beat poets of our
time
maybe all she needs is a little musical
accompaniment
space is exciting
it spurs
our imaginations
and it forces us
to ask
big questions
it affects us all
and it connects
us all
[Music]
oh
give it give it where it's due yes
because now it's interesting right yes i
was right it works perfectly i want more
perfect i want more that's your idea
yeah i could have listened to that for
five years 20 minutes it's shatner it's
pure shadow
i've heard that at a coffee shop in
brooklyn i would pay twenty dollars in a
really giant cup of tea to hear that
i mismatched smug oh absolutely would be
mismatched yeah the place smells like
candles but you still can't see
can i fact check that though what she
just she just said that space connects
us all no yeah face is what disconnects
yes
if if space connected us all and you
reached into a bag of potato chips it
would be one big chip
and you wouldn't have to reach because
it would already be in your mouth
so her understanding of physics is
absolutely the opposite of
mine that's another t-shirt yeah
you are a font yeah a t-shirt your facts
fall won't make the cut when as long as
she's got her little i'm telling you you
discovered how to make her successful
yeah like the sign language guy out just
about the guy with the bongos
i'm telling you it was when i was
listening to that i was like transfixed
yep i turned into maynard baynard krebs
wow yeah i think the beat the beat
references are are disappointing me
because i admire the beat poets yeah the
beat writers care wax one of my favorite
writers and uh despite her william
shatner imitation
she
she doesn't have rhythm
she doesn't have poetry she has speech
writers who know nothing but she
probably doesn't even but she doesn't
read it's that's what seems to be the
best but see her real job like any vice
president is to make her president look
good yeah and that's hard in this case
yeah so her job is to be even more you
know disorienting than the president
himself yeah um and she's doing great
she's doing great cat what do you think
i just every time someone resigns i'm
alarmed just like how many people are on
the staff yeah it's a lot like
it is like a chief of everything yeah
yes and she's i don't get it because she
still can't get anything done like the
stat if i had a bunch of chiefs
i would be so unstoppable yeah i i don't
i don't like it's hard to keep it all
tracked how can you still do nothing
when it seems that you have so many
people to do everything for you yeah you
have a chief to open your mail
that makes sure you're like how are they
all chiefs and then they're chiefs of
other people yes there's a lot of people
it's a lot of people in that and you
know what is she like is she one of
those people degen that like walks into
a room and is unaware that
over a short period of time people start
leaving the room
and she's not even aware of it until all
of a sudden she's like where'd everybody
go oh wow i guess the party's over but
she just doesn't know they're all
leaving because she's there
no i think that these women in power are
completely aware of how they are they're
just trying to fake it it's like hillary
clinton walking around acting
wondering why she's so unlikable and why
she lost the presidential election the
same thing with kamala harris it's like
oh i'm going to write a a
a
autobiography and i'm gonna call it uh
forgiving no you should just call it i'm
a [ __ ] and you can get ahead if you're
a [ __ ] like me
meaning that like that's a great title
for a book i that's the i have it
written down in my purse that's going to
be my book
instead of being the
and i've talked about this before i'm a
champion of women no
no you're not no you are a
shape-shifting
kidney shanker that's what you are and
that's how you got to where you are
today yeah anyone who says i'm not the
kid you have women that's a red flag
yeah
no such title exists
no no
everyone nope
doesn't exist uh kidney shanker is now i
is now my favorite term i shall be using
all weekend wherever i go it's a slow
painful death yes exactly kidney shanker
oh yeah slow bleed out you need a tissue
honey as they stand over you
you know i just
when do they find new employees like do
they go to linkedin
i mean like how do you get they got to
keep going they must have they have a
chief of lawyer
and then the vice president of that and
the chief the chief of the it's so many
people she doesn't have to think about
it one of her chiefs is on it yes all
right hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else